hello everyone welcome to the I think
it's the first uh wolfen language design
review of 2023
um if I'm not mistaken so this is part
of our incremental language development
uh series and we have a variety of
topics here
uh okay integer chop
so we started talking about this really
briefly
um in the previous meeting but the idea
is that chop is a fairly useful function
for taking approximate zeros down to
zero but it only works on zero
um it's more specific than round
obviously and Ed had put together a wfr
function that does this for arbitrary
units why isn't this floor
because it doesn't because I see because
it only does it within a certain range
yeah it's only doing it within a certain
tolerance
it's floor with a tolerance effectively
well I don't know they're round with the
tolerance right
yeah but it's none of the above because
it's not always making an integer
right
which is why integer chop isn't a very
good name for it because it doesn't
always make an integer that's its whole
point I mean if it's if it says yeah see
yeah it's sort of like a it's sort of
like a snack like it's snapping to a
grid or something but yeah this doesn't
make it as an easel
easel
well I know but that was a that's a
version one name that probably wouldn't
be
I mean this is
the smallest the same thing
well but now what what happens if I have
point you know if I have this institute
chop thing
and I have um
oops
and I have um
6.999999
what the hell is that
is that just a platform I think that's a
print form yeah
so it's a downward Chopper
I thought the chart it does within a
tolerance I mean 0.999 is not close
enough yeah you might need more nuns
but I don't understand because chop
do like ten nines maybe it should be
integer round
I think the point is not the Chop is the
problem the problem is the integer
that's a fair point yeah right I mean I
assume that the point is that there's a
two argument form where the second
argument will be you know one half and
then it will chop to the nearest half
yeah I think so well tolerance
that's
I don't know that's not the worst issue
in the sense that it's sort of an
extension
you know from a linguistic point of view
chop may not really make sense for the
6.9999999 case
yeah I mean basically what the the
overall goal of the function is take an
approximate integer and turn it into an
integer if it's within a certain
tolerance right right it is like
snapping to I mean it's like you know if
you use any kind of uh traffic Senator
thing it sort of snaps to a grid that's
that's exactly what this is yes enter
your eyes
but it's not integer
well again it I see that's I guess the
primary use but
I actually like Steven's name because
it's very much like rationalize I mean
yeah within the tolerance it works if it
can't it can't
well what what Christopher's bringing up
is is that we can extend it to
non-integers to other rationals for
example but we have many functions where
it's primary name yeah I that's what I'm
saying that that's why I also think
integerizes perfectly reasonable well
maybe the only other problem with
integer eyes would be and maybe well
I I'd be a little afraid that people
would say oh I've got something that
isn't an integer I want to make it an
integer and what they want is round or
floor or something like that and they
say oh integerized well rationalize
doesn't always return irrational right
there it's totally I know that point was
made but it's not clear yeah that's a
great feature of rationalize how about
round shop
it strikes me as incomprehensible sounds
like a piece of meat
it does
foreign
could rationalize possibly just be given
extra cases
no I don't think so I think it's too
obscure because this case here I mean
how does rationalize work let's see
I'm sorry it's unmute it's a continued
fraction approach no I know that I mean
it details it explains it's in the
details right but I mean also but the DX
here is the tolerance rather than a snap
grid
which is more useful maybe the tolerance
is the more useful second argument
I think to rationalize that's the case
for this integerized I'm less certain
I mean but chop also has a takes an
Epsilon right as its second argument
yes it does
which suggests this should as well
and then what if I mean it seems I'm
trying to think of when it'll be useful
to I mean if you wanted to snap to the
nearest hat or another version would be
uh maybe you give it a list of values to
snap to but I'm not sure how useful
those are I mean those are the obvious
generalizations
I mean I think
yeah it's either I'm trying to think
about whether that list of things you
know that's a bunch of catchment basins
so to speak that you're giving it it's
like nearest essentially
at that point
um
actually you could that's true and in
fact you can even write it with nearest
because nearest has a Syntax for um it's
a little obscure for for only finding
results within some radius
right
well I think we should consider
Enterprise I think it's some
I think it's an understandable name
and I think
it's
I mean
let me think about this for a second
yeah I think I think it's a reasonable
name anybody object here and we're
basically doing an X DX type of deal
okay I think that makes sense we'll
review it again and consider that when
we finalize it but yeah
okay
right we're just working around
that we're gonna round
um
why not if it's within the DX
just crush it into a miniature
seems right to me yeah I guess we do
intervals and quantities would be nice
maybe it was but not in The Voice
why
the whole interval is within DX
Maybe
also what's the default DX
presumably the one for Chop yeah what is
it like machine
it's not machine Epsilon
and just to make sure that we're all on
the same page it also works for
professionals that are a tiny bit of
I think so in gaussian integers
yes
well it's 10 to the minus 10.
now chops should really have a tolerance
option
no actually you're saying it has a
second argument yeah the way we do
documentation now we should put that
second argument up into the into the
main usage
yep I'll move that up
um
okay
hard body systems yes so we started
talking about this also last time
um we have Rob here also
um because we had talked about
potentially
either generalizing what we have in N
body simulation to work here also or
doing basically the same thing
for hard body simulation
right
and since you know the fact is that the
more I look into this the number of
people who've used hot sphere gases but
as a model for things or hard objects
it's just so freaking large going back
you know forever
and
and the main use today is active for
jamming natural Dynamics anymore
FairPoint
Okay so
the way you're doing this coming do the
jamming problems have
um multiple incidence issues
they're aesthetic they're not dynamic
they're not Dynamic at all no
yes otherwise they are not stable if
they not have multiple points
yeah but okay but I think the thing
we're trying to do here okay
I don't understand why we wouldn't want
something which is a combined end body
simulator and I mean you know things are
gravitationally attracted and then they
bounce off type thing
why wouldn't that be the um
uh what one one thing is at least my
experience that the uh it's sort of hard
to get simulations like that not to
not to have crazy like things like
right you you get sort of singularities
and stuff very very easily and you get
weird situations and what kind of
singularity
why it's me if you if you have
collisions it's sort of uh
um for example like if you have like
adaptive sampling the way I mean if you
just do it with like a one event kind of
thing it's going to be
well like there's standard ways of
solving uh the problem of Singularity is
without collisions like where you just
use some hooke's law thing when they get
too close or you just you know have a
tolerance where in this radius you just
don't apply the the attractive force or
whatever there's nothing that I found in
the past really like that for collisions
I mean maybe we can make something up
and it'll be close enough but yeah
like like within an Epsilon layer where
Epsilon don't know 10 to minus six-ish
adish uh we have uh potential that goes
smoothly from zero to Infinity
well that's not what these things I mean
look these hard spare simulations are
based on algorithms
that really are just geometrical
algorithms no no this was for the case
where we have both computational plus
parts here yeah I understand but that
seems like it'll be look the fact is
okay the question is is it really and it
may be essentially a different domain of
operation to be dealing with genuine
hard spheres as compared to dealing with
potential absolutely yeah well which I
think suggests yeah yeah okay fine so
then it's then maybe we should just have
separate functions and not pretend we're
going to do the two together that if you
want to do something which has some you
know repulsive potential at Short
distances then put it in body simulation
and maybe we have a standardized
potential that does that no yes and no I
mean what we do right now in N body
simulation is best differential
equations the name doesn't suggest this
in any form
well what else would we do other than
differential equations
I mean we're doing equations of motion
I'm confused but the name and body
simulation just suggests there are
interactions between ant bodies in this
exactly the case for the hot three agas
I know but people usually buy and body
simulation people have usually evolved
to mean this differential equation based
thing that's correct
yeah
I mean you could if you really won them
together you could have two separate
cases and you we just give a message if
somebody tries to mix but I mean that's
essentially having two different
interfaces anyway but then then it will
be end body simulation instead of
harmonic for example we'd say hard
sphere or something like this yeah right
well um I think one reason for having
two different functions is because we
might want different output forms
for the that's a good point because
there are discrete events in the case of
hard space which there are not
yeah that's a good reason to do that and
you know some of my experimental stuff
has output forms that we could possibly
look at it's not a list of coordinates
and times and stuff it's it's an event
list
yeah which is something we can get there
which is completely unavailable in the
Continuum case yeah
um yeah and then also I mean let's say
we're adding in gravity
well I think that the gravity will be
like we have one in-body simulation
solution between each event that happens
and the events
um are actually kind of like sing
singularities because they're involved
discontinuous changes
yes but is that realistic to have a
okay Quest I mean this what are you
proposing are you proposing some
combining function I mean let's just
let's just look at how the hard sphere
algorithm works these things are going
all over the place they Collide and when
they're done colliding or when they're
in between collisions or wall
Reflections they're just doing like a
Galilean translation yep
so the thing that changes in the
algorithm when adding gravity which I
think this is really interesting to add
gravity because then you know we could
do hard spheres uh bouncing in a
container or whatever that'd be pretty
cool I think but but the problem is you
will no longer be able to compute when
the next position happens
you can maybe compute when the next
Collision happens using something like
endbody simulation
that's not obvious to me it's not good
enough it would be awesome you have to
have an event and the time step would
probably have to be a set so small it's
not realistic in general what about if
you can symbolically solve the equations
of motion so for two bodies
yeah
even even uh hooke's law you couldn't do
for many
well you could make an approximation but
then yeah but then then we've got the
same problem of it being off you yeah
you might get one step false obviously
clever beta answered for hooke's law
yeah yeah
okay fine well I mean it suggests all
right so basically the conclusion is
let's be realistic in what's possible
and just say you know we are basically
for now we're just doing hot spheres and
we're doing you know we've got the end
body simulation and we've got hard
spheres
um
I do think that you know we are
beginning to to sort of um
go into a general domain
that includes things like agent-based
models I mean this is the same type of
thing where we've got properties of of
essentially discrete objects that then
have you know dynamical behavior and so
on and uh but I mean it seems like the
design of embody simulation okay who how
do people feel I mean the times I wanted
to use it it's the design has been
pretty decent
what do other people think
there you go
okay
and and how similar is that design Brad
or others to the hard sphere simulation
design
uh well one issue that I was thinking of
is like if the if the output of an event
chain algorithm is very similar to a
causal graph then
um the users might want to know where
the particular mass is that's at an
intermediary time
so there might be a different algorithm
that we would need for interpolating the
causal graphs
the point is that there are causal
graphs are a possible output for a hard
sphere simulation in a way that
obviously I mean
I've been looking at it lately that the
causal graph is actually the fundamental
output of the algorithm but it's
carrying a little bit of extra
information on the notes or on the edges
sounds right to me
right well interpolating function does
have a mechanism this was set up for the
win event stuff I mean I don't know if
it'll be useful but
um it does have a mechanism for
discontinuities and interpolation
between
you know for points in between
discontinuities
um that's that's uh I'm not sure that
that's the same issue what I'm really
talking about is like okay you have this
big graph with a bunch of nodes in it
and you don't necess and the notes kind
of have some time stacking but if you
want to find out where the node for or
where particle 3 was at you have to look
at the events that particle 3 was in but
in the linear order of events with time
you don't necessarily know where the
first three event is going to be nor the
next three event
so it's a little more difficult than
just interpolating
um the type of output that you would
give fine yeah so you need a different
data structure that's yeah you need some
interpolating function that's sensitive
to the data structure all right question
are we only doing hard spheres or hard
squares a possibility
well the hard Square code
I'm just thinking of it right now as a
Pathfinder whatever we get to work with
the hard Square code
we can potentially get to work with the
hard sphere code except that I think
that the hard sphere code is a is really
nice when it gives us solutions that are
entirely over the rationals those are
the easiest to compute we never lose
Precision but then with what I'm
expecting to happen with the hard sphere
case is that the even if we can get
exact numbers for intermediary States
they'll probably become you know huge
expressions
so that you know memory will slow down
the computations and necessitate numeric
approximations
okay
a couple thousand digits because this is
totally realistic
and you certainly can't do that with
algebraic numbers that many collisions
that you're talking right but okay I'm
trying to ask are hard squares a
non-rotating squares right yeah
the hard Square thing is great
how
how seriously I mean what are we going
to call this function
and are we mostly going to say it's a
hard sphere function but it'll have some
opportunity to do hard squares but
non-rotating hard squares
it should be a hard sphere based where
anything else is just uh um
I don't know
a curious extension
because because of the fact that it
doesn't support rotating you could just
claim that they're topological spheres
foreign
I think this is about geometry I know
but that would that would give you
freedom for all kinds of shapes
in the name yeah well I I haven't
actually asked a question whether it's
still possible to get Exact Solutions if
you allow weird weird shapes and
rotations
it's probably quite difficult but okay
let's go just go through this so
what we've got here
is some options so we don't have a
radius there's nothing like radius is
that there's in in
and body simulation
it's just Mass I mean here we also have
a mass presumably
we have the same things Mass position
velocity except these are Point
particles right
yeah
so we probably just want to call it
radius Mass radius position velocity Etc
default radius is one
right
and
we probably want to have I mean I don't
know what steps means
yeah but this thing here is a Time
parameter and it's the same deal as as
you know this would also have a Time
parameter presumably
yeah that makes sense
and and body simulation has an output
um
I think it has multiple output
possibilities
right
yeah you look at the the data it it
gives a data object which then you can
query for stuff you want
where does it say what you can query it
for well go to the go to the page for
endbody simulation data
where the hell's the information wait a
minute what the hell's going on here how
do I just get a list of positions
oh I see state of body right
yeah
well okay I mean this this seems about
right
with a given property here and then in
terms of this combined properties there
will be a causal graph as one of the
possible things here
right or instead but is the total
kinetic energy as a Time dependent I
mean it may be as invariant but it's
also is that evaluated per time
I I don't know can
yeah you can plot it for for the ND
self-situate simulation it's it's it's
evaluated as a function of time
and assuming it's a conservative
potential of some kind it should be
it should be constant
right
okay yeah so the causal graph is a
almost bigger so sorry no the 30 kinetic
energy is not preserved right because
there are interaction in the energies
the total the total energy that's the
third one there Michael's yeah I mean
it's not it doesn't always work that way
because if ND self has errors but you
know it can you see the variety of I
mean each time you should be able to see
the burial theorem is that true Michael
between the kinetic energy and the
potential energy I think in average if
you have enough yeah
okay
so
but looking at the causal graph is like
looking at the whole data blob and then
asking for a particular state of a
particle at some time is like looking at
a slice of the data block
look I think we've got a basic plan here
um these things about boundary
conditions
we obviously don't have that
in
the case of embody simulation presumably
we could
have an outer boundary
we haven't wanted that particularly but
I don't think about that for in-body
simulation data
an outer boundary for the
yeah there's there's I and if if I point
out the there's an example where it's
done in a in a region I don't want to
see an example I want to see it in the
documentation is it is there a way of
specifying
a finite size region in end body
simulation yes
and you don't but you didn't document it
uh that may not have been documented
that's very bad
no region wait a minute yeah yeah that's
right there I thought I thought it was
there but
all right well fine no I'm in
you know this is very lame documentation
I mean come on you we can do more than
10 examples here 11 examples for this
function with all these pieces please
could we add some examples
Rob
or if yeah I'll I'll talk to Rogers if
you can get somebody to add some
examples
well if Brad is looking at the stuff
maybe he could add some examples yeah I
probably could the virial theorem thing
sounds interesting to me yeah
well this is perfectly reasonable what
you have here where's the
um
uh there it is a disc okay
that's nice
that's nice that's exactly what we
should do here too
now I don't know whether there are
Graphics that are non-trivial in the
hard sphere
simulation case
um
maybe these things with Tails and so on
they might want to be one of the
properties
is something that can readily give you
that the tailed graphic so to speak
now I think that's another thing that
will be nice here too oh no I guess not
because you can't show Tails because
there are no
well we could show the instantaneous
positions of the bodies together with
their velocities as Tails
does that make sense yeah sort of like a
like one of those fish plots or whatever
whatever you call them yeah
at least as a wfr that should be a thing
we have
I mean I would even argue that that's a
uh you know having a type of plot having
something which is a um
you know position and velocity plot
would not be a terrible thing to have
as a standardized plot type
Michael or anybody else do you want to
comment on that
I don't think plots in general are what
people do in this world but much more
correlation function averages well I
know that's what they do in the writing
research papers but not what they do
when they're exploring things
I would like to propose
questions
that
we consider some kind of plot like this
that takes
um
uh you know x y
I don't know how we do it dxdy
I mean I I guess I've wanted this many
times I mean I've written it's not very
hard to write
but it just seems like the kind of thing
we should have some way to do
maybe it's effectively a velocity plot
of um
what is that called list
not stream plot but the other list
Vector plot
is that right yeah but that that kind of
plots a vector field doesn't it and you
just want to plot yeah a few points
that are not not the whole field so it's
a little bit different yes it is
oh no actually look
at given at specified points this is
exactly the thing I'm asking for
well then we just need an example and in
less Vector plot we need an example of
embodied simulation and then body
simulation we need an example for a list
character plot and then we have it
solved
that makes sense
yep do you want to do that Brad well
you're looking at this stuff sure yeah I
need to get some training on updating
documentation anyways
okay
all right so I think we have a plan here
um there's are there any other different
things that need to be specified other
than a radius option
the radius thing here and we won't have
a first argument
it'll just go straight into this list of
of parameters here and then we'll have a
time you know a time that we want to
compute it for
we should have the possibility later of
adding a string first argument that
makes the hard Sphere not actually a
hard sphere
does that seem reasonable
yeah or something to switch it over to
the hard squares you mean yes
there's one other thing that I could
think of in terms of the argument
structure that the calculation Works a
little bit like Nest while and you could
put a time in there where you know the
this mass of things that starts going
crazy with a bunch of collisions and
then the competition hangs
so you might want an extra parameter
uh as a cut off for the number of events
that you're willing to calculate
fine
well that's a Max I'm sure we've got
what's up Max collisions
option that could be reused for this
well Max iterations perhaps if you
consider a collision being an iteration
but I don't like that
a little bit too tricksy
I think it could be Max Collision that's
fine
yeah oh as an option because in the nest
while it is a full argument I know but
that's a very different kind of thing no
that's
I I do also think that it might be worth
supporting an up to 10 or something like
that
for the time
does that make any sense yeah
why up to because if it blows up yeah
yeah
makes uh exponentially small times it
increments before the next yeah but
that's always that's always implied like
ND solve we don't you I mean up to is
really an integer thing and and this is
this is a slippery slope
for example we integrate as far as we
can and then give a message
and it also shows in the result how far
you integrated I don't precisely yeah
and that might make sense here the
simulation data should so show that it I
mean that's one of the things here is
the simulation time right so
it would it would be nice to have a
periodic boundary conditions even if the
equations of motions aren't physically
realized in flat-based I'm sorry so what
were you saying Michael instead of
reflecting it would be nice to have wrap
around boundary conditions yes or a
single one so you can imprint to the
simulate the long Channel or something
like this yeah right but what happens
brand body simulation with periodic
boundary conditions do we have a way of
doing that because you have a region
option that doesn't give you a way to
make it periodic
no we don't have
but this doesn't really make so much
sense because they are the force field
would discontinuously change because you
go somewhere else but he always out
forces it's still at the smooth
condition of the past
when the topological doors
why can't you have for am I being silly
why can't you have forces on a Taurus
no no no you you can but but then Canada
you you flap around at the for a moment
the distance is suddenly change if you
go to the left side from the right side
I see yeah I see then you must really
embed it topologically yeah yeah on the
doors from the beginning
right
okay so how will we do that in this case
we'd have a region Arrow
well how would we specify the periodic
region then
it's got to be rectangular doesn't it
yes yeah I was thinking something like
uh
like uh
up down left right and uh reflecting
periodic absorbing
all right we have to but so this is
similar to our pde
boundary conditions in some sense do we
don't we have periodic value conditions
for pdes
we have to symbol we don't have a proper
implementation
oh can't we reuse that symbol at least
for this
um we'd have to talk to Oliver because
the whole not really because it it
requires a mapping from one parametal
sized of the boundary to another
pyramidalization on another boundary
all right so anyway more discussion
about what how to specify parallel
boundary conditions but clearly it's a
useful thing here
and do we want to talk about it more
right now I think it needs to be dug
into in more detail
and you're suggesting that we have
absorbing reflecting periodic boundary
conditions that would be the obvious
ones that come to mind
for classical mechanics
um
okay what is this mcmc
method from Etienne
I think that's a non-deterministic
solver
right
okay
what's the Dutch and in fact do here
this was etienne's pre-history
what is this doing and this is this
this is this is trying to determine
configurations of hard spheres is that
true
huh okay
what is the story of our implementation
or you know what we should do with you
know mcmc methods
Michael you've been talking about this
repeatedly
because it was the number one choice for
people in Kobe times to model covet
Publications
this case is now a little bit over
yeah when I saw it it was used for
cosmological parameter extraction
how does it
I mean is it not relevant for other
purposes
I'm just not sure what general stuff you
would have
yeah
I mean in general I think most mcmc
stuff it's basically uh I mean it's a
fancy random walk it's not not even a
fancy random walk a lot of the time
well what are you saying there's no
particular wrapper function that will be
useful for it
no not that I can immediately think of
I I think it would be filed under
probability and statistics because my
recollection of some of the stuff was
that you're trying to recreate a
posterior distribution or something like
that
right yeah like most of the uses that
that I've run into have been you have
some extremely complicated distribution
and you're trying to sample from it you
know quote unquote uniformly maybe we
already do this maybe this is what we
already do well no it's stuff like I
mean this one is a bit too hard I think
even gram CMC but it would be something
like you want to sample uniformly from
the set of all possible chess games
right that would be something you'd use
I mean I think that one is a bit too
hard maybe but that's the kind of idea
what does it even mean what does that
even mean
well would be if you have a set of all
possible chess games such as that exists
pick one uniformly
at random I see what you say well where
each one is weighted where a game is
weighted every possible beginning to end
game is equally weighted right I'll give
you an example of a concrete one right
where people use mcmc for this so if you
have say a big Network and I say
um partition this network into 10 pieces
that are connected 10 Connected
components and give me you know there
are many different ways of doing that I
want you to uniformly sample some random
partition of the network into 10
components
so people use mcmc for that and
basically the way it works is that you
you pick some arbitrary partitioning
into 10 components and then you do a
random walk where you sort of change
your partition little by little and you
can show that in the infinite limit it
could be this random walk forever the
stationary distribution is uniform and
and you're uniformly sampling
right
fair enough
so what's the thing about the likelihood
function
well
with the Monte Carlo Markov chain
which thing
well it isn't the input part of the
input specification or likelihood
function
I I'm not sure I think the main thing
that you have to do to to do mcmc so
first of all when you're doing the
random walk you generally have to to
weight the uh you in order for right you
have to wait the the different sort of
edges depending on the the degree the in
degree of the different vertices if that
makes sense so it's it's a biased random
walk depending on on how often you
expect to you know encounter different
neighboring vertices is that the
likelihood function I'm I'm not sure I'm
not sure
okay but
all right so the question there is is
there any packaging of this mcmc thing
what I mean this is very similar to what
we were talking about before with for
example this
um
you know
you're saying give me a random for
example a list a list with all kinds of
complicated characteristics you know
there are no pair of identical elements
together and there's a a triple at this
distance Etc et cetera et cetera and
then you say give me a random thing that
satisfies these conditions
right but there's no magic there like
you know in order to do a sampling like
that with mcmc you have to basically you
have to come up with uh you have to come
up with a random walk set up and you
have to prove like five things yeah you
just prove that you're gonna it's
connected and stuff like that
right I mean yeah
well I was just gonna say maybe one
General thing but I don't really know
enough about this to say anything I I've
heard so one of the big issues with mcmc
is that mixing times so that is you're
doing this random walk in in the
infinite limit you know you'll be
uniform but in practice well
I think often a lot of uses even you
know if you run it for a billion years
you won't even be very uniform but
that's a different issue but but there's
supposed to be um I think it's very hard
usually to prove uh just API all right
what the mixing time should be and so
I've heard that there are certain
visualizations that people use to try
and as their thing is running to try and
guess how mixed it is I don't know how
any of these work I don't know what they
are but I've heard that such things I
can guess it's yeah it's like making in
random cellular automata you make one
you know a change in one place and you
see how that grows
I mean I think the problem is actually
similar to one that genetic algorithms
have
which is with the genetic algorithms
have a fitness function but if the
fitness function or the likelihood
function have local Minima that are
significantly deep you might not be able
to yeah I mean it's the same it's the
same thing in all these different
schemes
but the question that I have is is there
a useful Packaging
of a function which we don't necessarily
know how to implement in many cases but
it's just given a constraint find a
random example that satisfies this
constraint that random instance
it is random instance but it's random
instance which we've only done for very
particular cases right now well but I
think there is not a general case no I
understand that but I'm asking we could
we might be able to pile on some other
things like some things with graph
properties and so on I mean I hadn't
really thought about this as a pattern
for um uh
what the heck is that one such as a
biomolecular what the heck is the
biomolecular case
in your sequence
okay but but so this random instance
thing is then becoming the carrier of
many kinds of things that could be of
this type
yeah I mean this is there's a more
General I think design thing about uh I
mean there are a couple functions like
random instance and delete object maybe
a couple others that have been these
cross-domain functions yes
yes but I think random instances but
what I'm suggesting here is that we have
a little bit of a think of how else you
know random instance will be increase
its visibility if it goes into another
five domains
and you know we've got specific things
like random word random point and so on
and we don't really have a good way to
say
I mean we don't have
we don't have a way to just basically
you've got to describe a set in some way
I guess
yeah it's more like you have an abstract
or not fully determined thing
yes and a particular instance of it I
don't I don't know that it's really like
sampling from a
distribution per second I mean even this
is sampling from the distribution
sure in a certain way
yeah
you know it's something from the space
of solutions not from a distribution
well just the same thing I mean it's
just a distribution where the
probability of returning integer is zero
but we don't know what the distribution
is that this generates there's like
Randomness in the initial conditions and
that it does some solving
right we don't know right we don't know
if the for example if the distribution
is uniform but but you know like uh
right I mean you know the probability of
returning each integers hopefully zero
but
well but also this thing is set up to
try and make nice looking instances not
to generate ones
right
I think I think the point the point
though is that random instance in
principle it's one argument is you know
its main argument is a distribution spec
right but I mean my question is this no
it's always so excessive I think I don't
disagree it's not a distribution it's a
set of constraints and it wants to get
one possible solution I don't think it
distributions okay sort of yeah I mean I
think I right as it's set up right now
you're right it's basically a set and
it's not saying anything about all the
things that's going to sample from that
set and not things that are outside of
the set because it's not saying anything
about the distribution exactly within
things of that set but if we had a more
general you know if if we wanted to make
all the random functions together which
I don't think we really want to do but
if we were you know that function would
take a distribution and I think these
sets of constraints can be thought of as
distributions as well it's just they're
not fully specific
foreign
instance is another example of something
fine instance is much like random
instance isn't it
what's the difference between find
instance and random instance
I I would have guessed a priori that the
difference is that random instance makes
more promises about sampling you know
uniformly or something so you know
that's not the case no I think it is the
case at least for the examples that we
have here in the documentation page but
why are we just talking about how the
geometric scene case it it you know it
tries to pick beautiful examples and
stuff like that
but it's still a much larger space than
like if you run it a thousand times you
get 950 different yeah if you like find
instance a thousand times you get
yeah okay so so find instance is
deterministic or random instance is not
like find instances is deterministic but
perhaps unpredictable
yeah this is determinate
non-deterministic and unpredictable you
can do random instance comma in sort of
table
yeah well who knows what the
distribution of these things is and even
what it would mean I mean it's a it's a
um
I think we should think about what other
what other things we could have random
instances of
because I mean like this for example I
don't really see why there isn't a way
to ask
for a random value of x that satisfies
this
right that is a well-defined thing
that's a you know it's a uniform
distribution let's say over this region
and that we presumably do have a way to
ask for that it just isn't packaged as
given a constraint and random instance
okay let's put this for another time you
know let's try and think about what what
random instances might be what other
things might be subject to random
instances
all right let's take a quick look at
some of these other items here if we're
ready to go on okay
this is something that we've suggested
off the cover a couple of times which is
that much like geoposition of an entity
should give a Geo position that data
objects I agree I think it should so the
main hitch here is that there are a lot
of possible date properties
um in some cases it's straightforward
you know date is fine for
a nuclear explosion or for a historical
event but for you know things like
movies it's probably a release date for
things like a dinosaur maybe it's
Discovery dates for buildings
yeah rebuilding is probably construction
end date but for a lot of other cases
maybe a date interval makes more sense
you know for a person date objects
maybe birth date there's a lot of
ambiguity in terms of what we would do
in a lot of domains and I think we
either let's think about that for a
second okay so there are dates that have
a look is Jose with us today uh he's not
here today we he's going to be back next
week for it okay
um
okay all right there are things that
have
definite
by the way I assume that date object of
an astral Position will extract the
correct thing yeah much like data object
of a Geo Position will extract the date
if that information is embedded
all right so the question here is
okay what are some categories I mean
look clearly a date object of like a
battle or something where we have well
okay what about a war that had a date
interval in other words can date object
date object supposedly returns a single
date object go ahead right I think it
would be very confusing if a date object
uh your data object of entity return to
date interval yeah I don't think it can
return a date interval without things
going awry the okay arguably could do
what date object of a date interval does
which is give you the first moment in
the interval but that's me going to be a
little confusing yeah I mean the other
thing is just I mean maybe that would be
the consistent thing to do if well okay
so I'm thinking of like for example I
think there are some cases maybe in like
military conflict data or stuff like
that where there are some entities that
have a date and other end you know
there's like a property where sometimes
it's a date sometimes it's a date
interval
right so you could never really return I
think there are cases like that and and
if if there were you could never really
return that unless you had some
convention like what you just said of
you know maybe you pick the if it
happens to be an interval you pick the
start or something
okay let's look at these which ones we
think are realistic okay
what is debate
probably like political debate
why the hell do we have such a thing
that might be a Dev mode one I ran this
uh internally so okay all right so like
holidays on there and that's not an
exposure okay board game release date is
okay I think
um
dinosaur absolutely not Discovery date
yeah
if there is a date it would be first
appearance of the dinosaur no we'll be
off by 100 million years or something
yeah it'd be a very coarse granularity
to begin with
I think in general Discovery date
doesn't make a ton of sense no I think
you want the discovery date you look for
it formulation date Maybe
yeah maybe yeah I'm a little worried
that I mean
right it's just that
I think it just seems like the whole
construction is a little bit suspect in
the sense of like is it really good code
to write data object of a person or
something even if you happen to know
that oh this would be the birth date
um
I think there are certain domains where
it's intuitive like we're saying you
know a historical event or something
like that if there's a finite let's just
look through this list okay dog breed no
element no exoplanet no famous algorithm
I think probably no gem no
I don't know maybe on this one that's
the same as the algorithm though I mean
I don't know are our games invented or
discovered or something especially math
games
those seem fa Financial is a no I think
I can't imagine why that would be useful
just get confused you know
genome assembly that one I think is a
yes
holiday what does that mean genome
assembly oh assembly 37 of the human
genome for example
lunar eclipse I would think yes
sure sure
sorry already for genome assembly though
I mean this is the sort of thing where I
think it could sort of get you into
trouble where you just say data
objective genome assembly but you don't
realize it's the release date and not I
don't know when the sample was collected
or something
well I think for that particular case
it's a reasonable thing because that is
the only date there is no sample
collection thing but but yeah
so this particular set here is just
instances of domains where we only have
one date property there's a whole
section below that where there's
multiple dates okay but let's look at
some of these of which ones I mean
things like mountains no way right no
way music album release sure why not
[Music]
um
same with movie I would say the same
thing I mean nuclear explosion
absolutely Planet absolutely not
right I think the cases imagine you saw
a piece of code where it said you know
date object of you know I don't know
pick your favorite move Star Wars and uh
you know would that be readable I think
that's probably a yes yeah
shipwreck is a yes
TLD is probably a no even though that is
a fairly well defined thing I just don't
think that's a okay that's a date object
of google.com does not does not make a
lot of that means right I mean artwork
sure completion date I would say sure
but what's the start date oh it's a
start versus computer Michelangelo well
no but you can't just say completion so
willy-nilly because we were just talking
about how the convention for date
intervals you take the first
I think by the time only the left foot
of the statue is done it is not a that
is not the date of the artwork
and I would say this this is the sort of
thing now where it's I just I'm I'm
afraid that it's just you know you're
gonna have a piece of code where it's
date object of you know David and it's
it's it's going to be like totally
unclear what that means I mean the
convention in our history is certainly
to use the completion date
you know you might have an interval in
some cases but
I think the point is that it's the El
Cheapo version I mean if you want to get
it right you're going to go in and look
which date is it but it's just the oh
I've got these things and I just want to
do some rough
yeah it's a it's a courtesy yeah I was
thinking it's analogous too geoposition
of France you're going to get an answer
it may not be you know maybe it's a
representative location that is a rough
approximation of it
it right I think that there's things
that have a moment in time like an
artwork has a plausible Moment In Time
even a bridge I'm I'm skeptical about it
I mean anything that's out there for a
long time in operation and it's not
something where
I don't know I mean do we have a
standard way by the way for like if you
know if you use Geographics you can give
it a bunch of entities or like geo-list
plot do we have a similar thing with
timeline plot where we've already
decided a way of resolving entities yeah
but that's what this is about
and that's what I mean honestly in in
resolving entities here for example for
people we really want the date interval
um which I don't think we have right now
do we
um
no there's not a single data interval
property there's a person if I say
timeline plot of you know Alan Turing
uh
no
I don't know
that is pathetic that's pathetic
right that should work
and it should work with date intervals
and yes that is going to require us to
have a canonical meaning just like
geoposition of France has a canonical
meaning for what that is I think here
you know the date interval
I mean like like country for example
presumably that is an independent state
I don't know maybe that one is hard to
do but I you know this should do
something
shouldn't the United States for example
be when the Constitution was ratified
not when Independence was won
okay what's this this is a this is an
example with historical events that does
an interval it does start and end date
well great so it's interesting other
people as well yeah
so we've already got a pattern for this
um
but we just need to figure out what some
of these ones are look things like you
know a manned space mission we can
surely manage that
the the date interval for that
maybe that's a good Baseline is start
with things that make sense on timeline
plot I'll sit down with
Brett and Alan and just kind of itemize
things fun I think the two cases there
are things that make sense in Timeline
plot I mean there's also the question of
whether if you give date interval of
something if you say data interval of a
person maybe it just Returns the correct
thing the correct date interval that
seems convenient and and some other
things historical period those all have
a definite start and end
right but but also the
um
uh there are things that have a Moment
In Time character to them
which can perfectly well return
something for date object
I think there are things where people
will kind of know that this is a
courtesy basically is what is really the
thing here if you want it more precisely
you've got to specify what property it
is
um
what on Earth is this oh that's a bug
that that's a domain that isn't exposed
yet but okay format right so I think
we've got a plan here so date object for
you know for the things that have a
single date date object is good for the
things that have a begin and end date
interval is good and timeline plot
should
try both of them so to speak should
appropriately surface whichever one is
the right one okay
and don't be too creative
yeah the it should be intuitive what
it's going to do if there's ambiguity
then it probably right I mean dinosaur
on a timeline plot yeah you know we know
what that is that is not sometime in the
1800s right right it's it's I want to
see whether the stegosaurus was alive at
the same time as the Iguanodon or
something
and probably out of date with my
dinosaur name so it's probably
discontinued by now
I think the Iguanodon was discontinued
um
okay all right okay so we have a plan
for this yes really happy with these I
think so I think we're going to we're
probably not going to get far with this
but we might we could just look at it
again
um
directed Zero do we have Rob here
because Rob will be relevant to that
right I've already already lost
well he's relevant to that if we have a
uh Michael might be relevant to that too
I don't know whether Michael has Michael
Michael's still here yep
would be nice to have
well let's have a discussion about it I
don't know enough about it
um
that's more complicated
clean up XML handling and trees isn't
that something that's underway now
Within
yes
okay
General algebra
whatever that means I mean that's sort
of universal algebra in some sense
being able to do universal algebra
having a convention for universal
algebra because universal algebra on its
own does nothing
Michael do you have any comments on that
I don't know enough what's exactly meant
here
it just means
I mean team's not even algebra honestly
it's even a pre-version of algebra
encoded
foreign
I think what this is about is arbitrary
binary and unary operators
the activity would be something that's
required
right yeah
or something
but then you would no longer call it an
algebra then you would preface I know
but that's what what people call
universal algebra was just a thing that
has operators and relations
and you don't specify the relations at
you know at the beginning you just have
an operator like a binary operator
uh
right I mean it seems like it might be
nice I mean it could be nice to have
something where you'd have like ring
plus ring times field plus field times
Etc
and it basically just assumes that you
know the variables on either side are
elements of a ringing field whatever
I do believe this is what we have with
the axiomatic theory of ring and field
and so on
yeah that is probably the nicer way to
do it
this is look this is part of the ongoing
discussion about formal variables and
what do we mean by a variable what do we
mean by an operator
because there's really formal operators
as well as formal variables whatever
happened to our formal variables
discussion
anybody know
can we can we look at that again we were
having this discussion about the meaning
of variables like a year ago
yeah I'll bring that up a little time
okay so every comment like something
that people do recommend is having a
couple of bit in OS for non-commative
multiply
mm-hmm
well we can look at that that's part of
the same story
all right let's that that's let's do
four variables universal algebra
non-community multiplied that's a topic
okay last item here softmax is there an
easy story here
I think the main easy story was that
there's a pretty closely related
operation that we do have a function
repo implementation of
but soft Max seems to be a thing that is
heard from
what's happening here why is it sorry is
this just to be a function for running
soft Max yeah
does the softmax layer not basically do
that
what is the lay oh
wait I'm confused by that because
I mean right I don't see how this is
just different from softmax layer also
yeah but but we we also tend to just
have functions that work on lists I mean
layers usually have a whole no but they
do work on lists so if you just do kind
of I mean if you just do softmax layer
open close of list one two three
pretty much all the neural network
functions you can you can apply the a
layer to a list and it will work
okay but is this function interesting
enough that it should just be available
as you know the function softmax of a
list
I mean I'm not sure when you would ever
do it outside of a neural network
what is the definition of it
I don't remember but it's some
exponential thing yeah so I thought it
was some well-defined thing like a
logistic
four minutes yeah it is it's a very
standard thing but I mean see we also
have you know cross entropy lost layer
should we have a function called cross
entropy loss
oh there it is by the way it's
normalized to be XP come a total
oh sorry when when softmax layer of
minus one over that's the default yeah
okay so
okay
what does the total do in the normalized
there we just need the probabilities to
sum to one
oh the total is is that the second
argument is what it divides by in order
to normalize them so the default is I
think Norm so that the norm is one but
if you say total then the total will be
one I see I see
I don't know I mean is this function
something that is useful in general
computation or is it only useful as a
particular hack in neural Nets
I've never seen it used outside of a
neural map
fine
anybody else got comments on this
I actually was Christopher
okay all right we can we can forget that
for now
um all right anything else here
okay until the next time
thanks a lot see you all soon bye